after the credits and mcedit scenes
rolled in the 2016 MCU movie Doctor
Strange viewers who stayed in their
seats caught one more sequence it's
centers on mordo a supporting character
who trains Dr Steven strange in the use
and History of Magic the after credit
scene really seems to set up mordo who's
portrayed by Academy Award nominated
actor chel edur for a solo movie Disney
plus series or significant plot Ark in a
future film in the sequence MTO
discusses the overabundance of sorcerers
on the planet with fellow magical one
Jonathan Pangborn as such MTO presumably
heads out to knock off some Wicked
wizards but viewers never see that
happen not even as a Multiverse
possibility in Doctor Strange in the
Multiverse of Madness in fact he's
barely in that movie